authenticity it's difficult to maintain  who you are over an entire career  there are ups there are downs any  thoughts on house that fast you have to  be to yourself uh oh god that's too much  to think about  uh cuz to me I don't give it oh that  much thought to me it's like I'm usually  what I mean to be honest about it I mean  you look at the things like what  happened with that flag right okay so  you're playing that duck you say some  things that other people don't  particularly like yeah whatever it  becomes bigger than it really is  yes and so what happened was uh they  fired me got loads of free publicity out  of it and then hired a guy to imitate my  voice for less money thus bringing  closure to a horrible tragedy